allez wayne nationaux prend forme au
quai sous bois un centre commercial
dédié aux marques de luxe à prix cassés
vont ouvrir ses portes dans le courant
du mois de novembre prochain une façon
pour les enseignes de se séparer de
leurs collections des années précédentes
est clair qu'en bien rencontré ce matin
bertrand qu'atos et le directeur général
de qatar ouest il fait le point sur le
projet et sur les retombées économiques
en termes d'emplois notamment
nous voici sur le toit du chantier de
wang chen paris le futur outlet de luxe
qui ouvrira ses portes le 20 novembre
aux clayes-sous-bois nous retrouvons le
porteur de projet bertrand catoe
directeur général de catinvest bonjour
alors les premiers magasins vont
commencer à s'installer dès septembre
qui va-t-on retrouver exactement alors
c'est la sempiternelle question on
retrouvera 112 enseignes de mode et de
luxe puisque wang chen paris sera le
plus grand outlet de france dédié à la
mode et au luxe avec un certain nombre
de marques que nous avons déjà dévoilé
pour parler du rez de chaussée qui est
sera donc plus accès streetwear
sports outdoor des marques comme
rossignol qui aura chez nous sans
première outlet en europe perd l'izumi
le spécialiste des vêtements de cyclisme
alors que haut niveau au premier niveau
on aura une offre qui sera plus axé
maison pour une petite part et pour la
majeure partie plus axé mode
access luxe et luxe avec
grande grande première aujourd'hui la
nouvelle de l'ouverture de deux plus
grands des plus grands magasins zadig et
voltaire
à qui ouvrira
donc chez nous sur le premier étage un
magasin de 450 m² qui sera le plus grand
magasin zadig et voltaire d'europe en
outlet et qui viendra à côté de marc
qu'on avait déjà annoncé auparavant
comme agnès b hoolywood jo il y aura
aussi des marques de luxe mais sur ses
marques de luxe vous savez que nous
sommes tenus à une confidentialité
absolue est donc là il faudra attendre
le 20 novembre pour les découvrir
attendre l'ouverture donc c'est out
lettre de luxe s'appelle one nation
paris nous sommes pourtant
clayes-sous-bois alors pourquoi ce choix
alors on est ancrée dans notre
environnement
régional est donc on est fier d'être
attelé ce bois il n'est pas question de
le cacher simplement on s'adresse à une
clientèle qui est très large une
clientèle qui est à la fois donc cette
zone de chalandise exceptionnel 11
millions d'habitants qui sont à une
heure de voiture de des clayes-sous-bois
et donc de wang chen paris et aussi ces
touristes qui se pressent par millions à
paris 29 millions par an la capitale
mondiale du tourisme est un versailles
qui a encore battu tous les records de
fréquentation l'année dernière mais donc
il nous fallait une dénomination un nom
qui soit plus rassembleur plus porteurs
qui soit faxé facilement mémorisable et
accessible à tous et donc on a choisi de
retenir cette cette dénomination cette
appellation de one nation paris qui
symbolise cette grande nation des
amoureux de la mode et du luxe
c'est qu'il ya eu enfin alpha bâ requins
alpha park 2 prochainement alpha park
iii est ce que savait pas finalement
trop de concurrence c'est tout l'un
verse c'est pas c'est pas une
concurrence et profiter mutuellement
d'une zone commerciale qui clairement
devient une de ces zones prime on sait
que le commerce en ce moment vit des
heures difficiles et ça se traduit par
une séparation une dichotomie est de
plus en plus clair entre des zones qui
souffrent et dont certaines vont
disparaître malheureusement et des zones
qui deviennent de plus en plus
attractive qui offre comme celle de des
clayes-sous-bois de grand plaisir une
palette d'offres notre offre sera
évidemment tout à fait particulière
viendra en complémentarité des offres
qui sont aujourd'hui présentes
aujourd'hui 350 magasins présents à
sur la zone de grand plaisir et les clés
se boit on va en apporter sans doute
supplémentaire qui ne sont pas
concurrents le qui viendront apporter
leur contribution ce dynamisme
exceptionnel de cette de cette zone
commerciale dont on se réjouit
évidemment grandement de dynamiser
encore un peu plus la zone il y à peu
près combien d'emplois de prévu dès 2014
alors on est déjà aujourd'hui en
relation avec pôle emploi les services
de la mairie
donc vous trouverez sur notre site
internet toutes les informations
nécessaires si vous souhaitez postuler
pour un des emplois un des huit cents
emplois qui seront générés par parce par
ce site parce que à l'horizon
quand on sera à 100% plein 100% ouvert
ce seront huit cents emplois équivalents
temps plein qui seront générés par one
nation paris une dernière question
l'investissement et à hauteur de 107
millions d'euros
finalement à quand estimez-vous être
rentable j'aimerais bien pouvoir
répondre à votre question non loyer
sont des loyers variables ils sont
indexés sur le chiffre d'affaires de de
nos enseignes de nos partenaires des
marques et donc tout et banderas du
succès de l'accueil que wang chen paris
aura auprès de pressions publiques et ça
il faudrait attendre un petit peu pour
le savoir
merci beaucoup voilà un centre
commercial qui va donc créer de l'emploi
vous venez de l'entendre environ 800
emplois et qui sera aussi générateur de
nouveautés architectural écart cambier
fait également le point sur les avancées
en cette matière petit à petit sur ce
chantier des clayes-sous-bois la
houlette de luxe one nation prend forme
les travaux devraient se terminer en
novembre cet espace de 24 mille mètres
carrés accueillera des enseignes de luxe
qui proposeront leurs collections
passées à prix bradés pour coller au
standing de ses magasins l'architecte a
cherché à se différencier des centres
commerciaux classiques on trouve le luxe
par la lumière et la matière donc si
vous regardez autour de vous vous avez
la matière qui est brut partout du métal
ou du béton blanc très dominants et de
la lumière on a travaillé donc avec une
grande verrière qui permet d'amener la
lumière en tout point du centre avec des
grandes trémie sur le plancher le
plancher bas qui permet de descendre la
lumière partout dans le centre et
partout dans le bâtiment en tout une
verrière de 5000 m² dans les allées les
espaces à ciel ouvert donneront sur
trois patios à l' architecture
parisienne ici se tiendront les jardins
à la française
ici la cour de marbre et enfin la place
de l'étoile
en cas d'intempéries la pluie sera
récupérée pour la réserve incendie
l'arrosage autre aspect écologique une
boucle d'eau sera mise en place avec le
futur data center de la société bull
pour récupérer la chaleur des
ordinateurs à terme
wang chen devrait accueillir 5 millions
de visiteurs par an dans cette zone où
la circulation se fait déjà dans ce
les aménagements extérieurs sont sont en
cours on va essayer de fluidifier au
maximum les accès donc grâce à des ronds
points
on pense aussi à développer des parkings
extérieurs en rachetant des terrains
alentours sont restés de de faire le
maximum
pour que les nos visiteurs puissent
accéder à ce bâtiment le plus simplement
possible
1200 places de parking seront également
créés au sous sol
en novembre le taux d'occupation devrait
atteindre les 70 % majoritairement des
magasins mais aussi un espace
restauration et des services
les one nation à paris au quai sous bois
c'est un centre commercial j'ai envie de
dire de plus proposer aux consommateurs
dans une zone qui est déjà très dense
avec alpha part que 1 et sa part que
deux et bientôt elle fait part que toi
dans l'ancienne galerie les sablons un
plaisir alors est-ce que cela ne fait-il
pas pro et est ce que les clients aiment
les centres commerciaux c'est en tout
cas la question que nous sommes allés
vous posez ce que j'aime pas dans les
centres commerciaux c'est gabriel aurait
augmenté les bruits pas du tout mais
parce qu'il n'y a plus d'autres
commerces
mais si je pouvais je le dirai plutôt
marché ouais j'aime les centres
commerciaux sur sa pratique quand on
veut faire des achats divers et variés
l'avantagé c'est que ça propose pas mal
de trucs pour dans un même lieu oui
j'aime les centres commerciaux parce que
il ya un choix de boutiques voilà on
trouve il ya une diversité de choix de
boutiques qui me plaît bien quoi ah oui
j'aime bien les centres commerciaux
parce que d'abord quand il ya des offres
exceptionnelles c'est très intéressant
et puis entre eux on trouve tous n'ont
pas spécialement parce que c'est tous la
même chose parce que regarder pour se
garer c'est impossible c'est n'importe
quoi